Let's say we operate in a world where
um you believe Pixie is pursuing that maliciously. Okay, I you
don't have to, but somebody somebody argues she's pursuing it
maliciously. Would you accept the argument from somebody else
that it's okay because Destiny's an elsewhere and it's so it's
okay
to have him be like financially ruined by this because he was
an on Twitch for so long. >> I I mean it wouldn't be fine.
So that's like the >> So it's like totally but you have
to say that's totally fine, right? I would say like it's the
exact same concept, right? >> I think it's it's the combination
of the threat and the pull back. Always have to get up to pull
back. >> But hold on, hold on, hold on. Destiny could have
just like settled this, right? He could have just like apologized
and settled this and been like, "Oh, I'm really like I'm so sorry.
I shouldn't have done this. It was really up. [music]
Can I argue with you?" Oh. Oh, yeah. Oh, let's go. Hop on the
stream. [music] Oh, stale 2000. Let's go. I didn't see stale.
What's up, buddy? Hold on.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Wait. Do I have to limit the size
of the waiting room at the Collins room? I probably do. I wouldn't
wouldn't want any demons bringing their influence in.
Okay, let's see. [clears throat] Hey, St. How's it going?
Doing all
>> Hold on. Let me make sure this overlay is working again.
Oh, it is. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool.
What's up, man? How's it going? >> Doing all right, actually.
Yeah. So, I I got a couple things I wanted to to bring up with
you. Um, so one, I noticed that you reacted >> to my debate,
and I will say that I was a co-creator of that debate, and you
may have infringed upon my uh copyright.
I'm kidding. But, but um I almost think that would be true,
right? like um I almost feel like um
my basic premise of of this of my debates and and and all this
stuff was that copyright law is like so insane that almost everybody
is vulnerable right now and people are just kind of hoping
>> that it's not the case I guess and so I almost think
like you actually agree with me a lot more than I think that
Pisco did and that like you were talking about like Pandora's
box you were talking about how it was being opened and I actually
agree I I think that like things could get Yeah. completely
maybe we should we should talk about that [laughter] like I don't
know what to say. >> Yeah. I think doing like a hugely
published case when you're clearly aware of this fact and in
fact with this like explicit idea in mind. Um if if he just But
by the way that's why in my opinion this shouldn't even exist.
This whole registering with the Library of Congress thing so
you get statutory damages. That's the only problem to me. Right.
If you just want to go to court and argue for damages plus like
your legal fees, I'm good with that. But that's not what he wants
to do, right?
>> Sure. But but that's not what the law is, right? So
>> it's not. Yeah, it's not. So I think drawing attention
to this over and over again is obviously horrible for like all
React content. I think Ethan has has defeated he's already his
stated intent. He went I don't want to chill Asmin Gold or XQC.
No, by filing the lawsuit, you have raped Jasmin Golden XC like
>> Would you agree with me? >> Sure. So, >> and
you're just like, well, but somebody was somebody was gonna rap.
It's the rape. It's the unironic rip cage. Somebody was going
to rape. Okay. And it it's now happened. Yeah. >> That's
that's half true. But I more meant like I I feel like you're
coping when you say that like this was not going to blow up eventually
and like maybe it needed to blow up sooner. [laughter] Like imagine
what I'm saying is like I feel like over the years people have
gotten very safe. >> So you're just making like an accelerationist
argument, right?
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> All right. Yeah. I think accelerationism is stupid.
>> Well, maybe a little bit, but but it's I don't know.
I I just feel like people are coping a little bit too much and
like I
>> What was the cope?
>> What did you think was going to happen? Did you think
like nobody was going to notice this? Like I feel like all it
takes is one person. Well, like even like um even like somebody
like literally me, right? Like I mean I've been reacted to like
start.
>> Lots of times when people do this, they don't go and
like announce their explicit intent to like do things in a very
specific way that will force the other people into financial
ruination in a way that like nobody's talked about using for
content before and then use it for content on their massively
popular podcast. Right. So, like he explicitly went on an advertising
campaign for this like poison pill that you can inject into any
content after the fact even for anybody you hate and then sue
them. >> And he just did a massive PR campaign for it.
>> So you So you actually think like nobody would have
noticed this at all? It would have been like >> somebody
might have noticed it, but I think Ethan Klein doing it for totally
disingenuous and like self-motivated reasons that he is the person
who did it and he did it because they laughed at
He's like a tiny pathetic worm loser and that he did this he
like set this whole thing into motion because he is a like small
petty loser.
>> Well, I mean I'll
I'll say I'll 20% >> You could say you could say it was
going to happen always. So why not a small petty loser if you
want to make that argument but he is a small petty loser. >> I
I Okay. I think he's only 80% a small petty loser cuz I I do
think that like these people were a little bit beyond the pale
here. Like like these people were like >> Casey Tron was
totally beyond the pale. Casey Tron was totally beyond the pale.
Not not in terms of I don't know about her commentary beforehand,
but like obviously Casey Tron's guilty. Obviously Casey John
infringes IP. Casey John's like disgusting.
>> I I more meant like on her criticism. Like maybe maybe
it's okay a little bit to go after him. >> What was her
criticism? >> She's just like on Twitter doing like saying
derange all the time. I I don't know. I don't know about >> what
did she say about Ethan?
I don't know about Ethan specifically, but I do know like like
she'll just do >> Hold on. So, wait, wait, wait, wait.
You just said Hold on. You just said that she was totally deranged
on Twitter about you said that it was because of her rhetoric,
the things she said. >> Yes. Yeah. So, so I was thinking
of of other [clears throat] situations. So, so for example, um
this is a very old situation where she just like nuked Ninja
for like no reason. >> Ninja Hold on. There's like nothing
better than the Asmin Gold one. That's like a really bad one.
She was really really like borderline evil to Asmin Gold. Okay,
so that's the best one. If you're going to sit here and argue
that like it's actually not that bad because she was mean to
Asminold for Ethan to sue her for copyright, that's like multiple
levels of indirection. That makes no sense to me. Ethan Ethan
doesn't get any credit for that. If Asmin Gold wanted to sue
her or do whatever he wanted like I thought Asmin Gold was handling
it the correct handling it the correct way for somebody who's
a content creator. The way you handle it the code of honor in
the content creation space is you make content about it. You
call them a loser. You go and you make content. You call him
a loser. And that's what Asminold did. Okay. Hast Tron said,
"I I think you killed your mom, you sick." And he went, "I'm
going to make your life horrible forever, you fat bitch." And
then he endeavored to do that. And he has been doing that. That's
I think the That's the game everybody plays. And Ethan realized
that he was losing. >> Yeah. No, that's the game. That's
the game Asenold's playing. That's the game that Ethan lost at
and he tried to do it and he lost at it and now he's upset. He's
acted mad and so he's going to >> Yeah. So I guess there's
two separate issues. There's one which is about the copyright
thing and another about like okay are are you deserving of bad
consequences if you're going beyond the pale, right? Like so
I I mean I would I almost argue that like what you're describing
is like kind of bad. I'm not saying that people can't do extreme
criticism. It's just people should not
retards about it, right? Like that that's the only way that I
have to say like you should be careful about it. You yeah go
in on your hard criticism, your insane, but be smart about it.
I don't feel like you can be dumb and insane at the same time.
Um, but that's almost like unrelated to the to the the DMCA
>> Yeah. So, I just don't think you can like I don't think
you can say I'm going to sue Casey Tron. I think this would be
a totally insane thing to give Ethan a passport. By the way,
in terms of legal rights, Ethan can sue whoever he wants. Obviously,
right? He's doing it right now. I don't deny that. I'm saying
basically everybody who does criticize people, who does commentary
on the internet for a living should look at Ethan and go, you're
a disgusting loser who's trying to ruin this entire space. You
you actually should he should be a total social pariah within
the content creation space for doing this.
>> Sure. So, so we're seeing a whole bunch of creators
embrace him, which is sad, especially if it's on the basis of,
well, Casey was like a mean person once. >> Sure. So, so
I'll let I'll just give you that for the sake of argument. >> But
do you think that solves the problem? Like imagine >> before
you give it to me for the sake of argument. Before you give it
to me for the sake of argument, do you agree?
>> Um, well, okay. I'm a bit of a the ends justifies the
means kind of a person. I think that if somebody I'm more of
a talk, [__] get hit kind of a person. I Nobody's
going to agree with me on this, but I think if you talk [__]
you get hit. Um, but but that's that's >> Yeah, but hold
on.
>> there's something there's like um what do you call it?
Like there's reasonable escalations within any conflict, right?
I don't think it's reasonable to go from you suck. You fed your
dog cheese to hey, actually dance in a circle and say I'm a little
piggy Caseyron or else I'm going to take your parents house away.
>> I think that's like an insane escalation. That's totally
disgusting.
>> So So I I'll actually address this. I think that if
Ethan actually ruined her life, I I would actually agree with
you. But he gave her a way out, right? Like like so like Casey's
wife is actually technically borderline neutral at this point.
Like like she got she you know she did the the crowdfunder and
all she had to do was pay off the money she got and like I guess
she's embarrassed. Like you're right she's embarrassed but I
don't think that's that big of a deal. >> Okay. Uh do you
like any small content
>> Sure. Yeah. >> Like I'm asking can you name one?
>> I don't know. I don't want to make a
what's your I mean I don't know like Gappy VBS. >> I'm
literally just going to use Okay. Let's say let's say a very
rich person who you don't like. Let's say Nick Fuentes gets one
of his pieces reacted to a piece of political content. They watch
one of his whole videos from somewhere and he decides that he's
going to register it with the Library of Congress. Okay. Oh,
>> I didn't just shut something off, did I? Hold on. Hold
on. Okay. He's going to register something with the Library of
Congress. Okay. And he's going to sue that person. It's somebody
you like, a small creator, right? >> He can now financially
like ruin that person's. He's got the ability to do so. >> And
would you think it's good if if he said, "Okay, in exchange for
that, you're gonna actually like do a whole bunch of statements
apologizing me apologizing to me for critiquing my political
content, like for your critiques of my political arguments.
>> You think that would be reasonable?" Then you go, "Oh,
actually, it's not that bad. He just extracted a bunch of concessions
about politics. That's all he did."
>> I mean, I I will actually make that statement. I I think
that if somebody is going okay if somebody's being very very
meaning mean and somebody like does extract those concessions
I I don't think that's that big of a deal right so I obviously
if Ethan actually
>> just to be clear you have not even said what you think
the bar is for very very mean to Ethan so if they were very very
mean to somebody who is a total a let's say they're very very
mean to I don't know Donald Trump would that be a good reason
to do it
>> no well that's I I mean, maybe if John
Okay, that that's that's a very political figure.
I mean, I
Why does that matter? >> Yeah. Maybe not for him. Like,
okay. I I feel like >> you understand there's a lot of
people who legitimately don't like Ethan,
>> Sure. Yeah. >> A very divisive figure. He has
very stupid like total ego fest with people all the time. Massive
splits in his audience multiple times throughout his >> Yeah.
But I I feel he's still not a politician, right? So like yeah,
you can you can do your criticism of him, but like be a little
bit
down. >> What was the issue? What was the issue everybody
was mean to him over? I forget. Was it a political issue? >> Uh
I mean there's there's a lot of different issues, right? Like
there is political there's the Israel stuff. There's him being
like married to a there's there's many different things related
to him. I don't I don't know what case you're on.
>> It's the it could be the Israel stuff. It could be the
Israel stuff or you know many different things.
Um, okay. There's his fights with Hassan.
Uh, there's >> over what?
>> Well, that is over Israel, but I I there's I mean, I
hate to bring keep bringing that up over and over again, but
that that's the
that's the thing being talked about, right? >> So, he's
a reviled person because of politics. By the way, I'm I'm not
going to say anything about why or or if I agree with that that
statement, okay? But like he is a reviled person because of a
polit because of political statements online. I think personally
that's quite unfair. But again, we've just created nothing but
like a subjective rubric, entirely subjective rubric for how
we determine whether somebody has been mean enough to deserve
to get sued and have their life threatened, their their their
well-being threatened, financial well-being. >> It's not
It wasn't actually threatened, though. Like like it it was like
the
>> No, it was actually threatened.
>> Okay. It was threatened, but it didn't follow through
on it. >> No, it was Hold on. So, just to be clear, it
was threatened because Ethan literally had
Ethan literally had a gun to her head and said, "I am totally
legally entitled to pull this trigger." >> And you're saying,
"Oh, well, he wasn't actually threatened."
>> I I I
think that's a big difference from actually pulling the trigger.
I I think that if if >> No. Okay. Not in terms of it being
a threat. That is the definition of a
>> Sure. But there's a difference between following through
on a threat versus actually making it.
Yes, sure. Well, no.
Sure, sure, sure, sure. There's a difference between, but I think
Oh, man. Uh,
okay. Let me rephrase. Let me give you my my overarching philosophy.
I if somebody is unwilling at all to back off in in like any
minor way, I almost have no sympathy. And so, like, you're right.
She was offered this huge threat which could have destroyed her
life, but she was given an out. And if you don't take that out,
that's almost like on her at this point. And so, like, if you're
not willing to do this, >> hold on. >> Hold on. I
think if the threat was
um you have to admit you infer my copyright and that you're a
piece of [__] for doing that and maybe at most for
talking about my wife, okay, you apologize for those two things.
I'll let you off the hook. The fact that he's injecting in there
about Asold's mom is totally insane if he did. Again, I I think
it depends. I didn't ask you about this, but what are your thoughts
on that apology? It seemed like it was probably mostly points
given to her by Ethan that he wanted to hear, right? >> Yeah,
I'll I'll agree with that. Yeah. [laughter] Um >> Okay.
Okay. Some pe Well, some people totally disagreed and I was like
that shocked me, but >> Okay. All right. So, I think when
he puts in totally unrelated is like you have to say all this
unrelated [__] >> I think that's insane. But
does it actually harm her that much more? I guess it harms her
reputation, but how much does she have a reputation? >> I'm
sorry, but you're an American,
How important do you think it is to not have your speech be compelled?
Cuz I think most Americans are like, "Oh, that's like one of
the most important things in the world to have somebody control
your speech. That's crazy."
And I don't think like in terms of a lawsuit, I don't think it's
wrong for you to get an apology over the thing you're being sued
over. the like actual like illegal the the outside the bounds
of the law conduct, but she didn't apologize for the outside
the bounds of the law outside the law conduct, right? She apologized
for totally like okay on the internet, not even really that crazy
>> I don't know if you noticed this, but tons of people
talk about his wife.
>> I got a whole segment here I could show you. You can
sit here and react with me. We can watch Mike David say she looks
like office furniture. Okay. Yeah, I I' I've seen this. I mean,
I've seen the the small stuff and the huge stuff. >> Okay.
So, like I I just think it's crazy. I like on a personal level,
I think making comments about people's parents is gross. But
I don't think I would never argue that that should be a rule
that if you make a comment that somebody like their mom, oh well,
now they're open open season, boys. Has they ever reacted to
a full video? Get them. I think that's a crazy bar to set. >> But
like
I don't know. There has to be >> I get it. So, I just need
to I need to let you know that your your position is Yeah, but
this is really this is rancid. That's like your position. I get
it.
>> But like you should probably know the things you said
about Ethan. >> No. No. Okay. It's two things. It's being
rancid and also being given the way out. And if the somebody
doesn't get the doesn't take the way out,
like
I don't know what to say. Like you should be g like you're right.
like if somebody's life is ruined, but you should be given multiple
opportunities to calm down, to pull it back 10 20%. And if you
do that, you're good.
I I don't know. You're just a
um I
sure that listen, that could be true, I guess, but again, that's
going to have to be that the conduct was was the thing like outside
the law to begin with, right? I think making them apologize for
totally different things based on a copyright lawsuit is insane.
>> Yeah, I mean I get that. I I just I don't I Yeah, I
don't know. I don't know if we have to agree to disagree that,
but but I don't know. We're going a little bit in circles on
that, but I I understand your your perspective, but I just don't
I mean I very much >> Well, I'm telling you that like that
obviously leads to totally crazy in the content creator space,
right? >> It does not though because all somebody has to
do is chill out. All somebody has to do is pull back a little
bit. >> No, you you've Hold on. pull back a little bit.
You I've explained to you already it's a totally subjective line.
You have a totally subjective take on this. You've you've provided
no objective rubric by which we measure this. Where's the line?
The line is wherever you say it is.
>> The line is is
yeah being very offensive while also being vulnerable. But there's
two ways of of stopping this. You can be not vulnerable or not
being offensive. Like like you can do both or like either way.
That's what I'm saying is like I I respect being beyond the pale
if you're smart about it. Like like you gota
I just don't respect people who just things out from the hip
for no reason and are dumb. >> I think Denims [clears throat]
was smart about it though. That's the problem. I think Denims
was smart about it. She's still getting sued.
>> Was she smart? Well, see she she still
>> her reaction totally transformative.
>> I I don't know. I I don't know about to >> Oh,
sorry. It's sorry. It's transformative the standards the current
standards of the commentary community. The any no more more it
was more transformative than XQC and a bunch of other people.
Um if I could show you a clip of Nicholas Yorio actually thinking
he did a longer react and he did a shorter react. Okay. He miscalculates
the minutes. He she did more time than Nicholas Dioro. She did
more time I think than almost anyone.
>> So So I'll agree that she >> like it was actually
critiques and stuff too although some other things. Sorry. Go
ahead. Yeah, I I'll say that I think that she was more transformative
than the um the status quo, right? Like the the common
uh expectation, but not the >> Well, where wherever the
bar is. And by the way, his whole argument around React and how
it was bad and and like posting to all of Ethan's points, everything
he chastised XQC for, had a debate with him for, XQC did all
of those things with the content nuke. He's not getting sued.
the Well, it doesn't have the state of malice though,
>> which is not the law. >> The state of malice could
be the state of malice could be Ethan's like thing that he wants
to sue on, >> but unfortunately
unfortunately for him, he's already put on the record that he
believes XQC does this maliciously, like intentionally to siphon
views. So, the intention the the actual malice that is there,
he attributes to XQC already. He's always attributed to XQC.
He doesn't believe commentators take the thumbnail and like the
title and match it almost perfectly because it's oh it's just
like coincidental. He thinks that's intentional to siphon views.
So he believes XQC is intentionally doing it. So do you think
that Ethan Klein is a total who thinks someone saying I'm going
to punch you in the face and then not doing it is different than
somebody saying I'm going to punch you in the face and then actually
punching you in the face. Like basically he thinks both people
are doing the action. One of them is just announcing it. Right.
My position is that he walked that back on XQC, right? So you're
you're right on like a year ago. >> Wait, where did he
walk that back on
>> I I think in his video he talked about how like oh if
you generally uh you know tell like give recommendations to watch
on the YouTube video if you have commentary if you don't try
to screw somebody over. He gave these excuses. I don't I really
need to go look at back at the video, but he gave some excuses
why the standard XQC Asmin Gold React situation wasn't really
that bad, even though it might be illegal. And he he chose he
said he said the only thing was the stated malice, but he already
he already took XQC saying, "I don't have malice." And said,
"You're lying. You do have malice, and I can tell it you do."
Right. And he's never I don't think he he's ever walked that
back. >> Did Did he say that a year ago or did he say that
in the new video? cuz I I do feel like he said >> he didn't
say that in the new video, but he used the new video to say like
this is my cause. He used the new video to say this is my cause
to fight for >> Yeah, but he he still
created a distinction from the Twitch stuff versus the state.
>> So my my argument is okay, it's just the piscal argument
is very easy. The distinction isn't on anything that he's actually
said. The distinction is just denims is an app,
>> right? Denims did. That's like the distinction. That's
the obvious distinction. Okay. >> Yep. Okay. That's like
the obvious distinction. So, he's just using it maliciously based
on some other drama he's been in,
>> which is again, he's totally
legally. He's he's totally authorized to do that illegally, but
now he has put the entire React community into a state where
it's like kind of nuked. Like it people don't realize it's already
cooked, right? He's we've like had the bomb go off and there's
a whole bunch of people who are actually like walking zombies.
Like their whole immune system's gone. They'll never they're
going to die of radiation poisoning, but they just don't know
it yet. That's like the entire React community. >> Well,
so so I wouldn't even call that malicious though, right? So like
um I almost would say that's stupid. >> It is malicious.
No, it is malicious.
>> Imagine you're borrowing a car from somebody or you're
you're getting some property from somebody. You you almost owe
them respect. So, like the fact that somebody is disrespecting
that uh benefit that you're being given almost is a valid reason.
>> Um I maybe you could argue that at least with Denims,
he made this video mostly to contend with like these people specifically.
No, like Hassan, the whole community. Like he made the video
explicitly so they would react to it, >> Yeah. Um, like
>> so he made the video planning to sue them, knowing that
they didn't respect him and hoping that they would react to >> Yeah.
Knowing that they might disrespect them. They knowing they might
go over the line and and be very bad people and >> the
same way he does, right? He reviews their content, they review
his content. >> Yeah. Well, but he doesn't. >> So,
he took he took like the status quo. This is why I think there's
going to be an argument eventually that somebody will say like
I think there's an implied license here, right? because it was
the status quo. He made the content. Even acknowledging that
he wanted them to react to it, that he was planning on them reacting
to it. He made it explicitly for them to react. Playing on that
thing, that back and forth. >> I'll even like I think that
that is probably the best argument like the implied license like
like maybe there's some sort of status quo about how people react
to things, but yeah, I I don't know how to I don't know. Most
copyright lawyers would say no, but but like
but that that's probably the best thing. Yeah, that's the best
argument is the implied license. Uh, well, I I I still don't
think it'll work. I still think Denims loses that case. I think
Denims loses that case. I think Casey Tron and Frogan almost
certainly would have just totally lost the case. >> Sure,
but like what if they just apologize as well or something like
like they could get out of it too. >> Okay. Even if he
just accepted an apology for stealing the content, I again, if
the apology was I infringed on his copyright, I was rude about
it. I apologize. If that's what he extracted, I'm totally cool
with it.
Why does Denims lose the case? Because no reaction to any full
video is transformative.
No live reaction to a full video is transformative. I'm going
to say that is a line that for YouTube content they will say
that they will set that precedent. >> Okay. So let me go
in a different direction cuz you're talking about this morality
thing a bit. Um what are your thoughts about this nuclear weapon?
Right. Like so did you think people were going to be safe? Do
you did you think like if we just covered our eyes it was going
to go away? Uh maybe you're right on that. or or was this
a bomb that was always going to go off and maybe people should
have stopped using >> I think I think people using it for
a publicity stunt was pretty insane and and it's put everybody
else at risk and in the exact So there's the combination I haven't
written this out so it's just kind of mulling around in my head.
So it it's a combination of fully publicizing it using like this
this preset up method and uh there's one other thing. Oh um hold
on. Oh, and saying that you didn't want to harm the rest of the
community, that your goal was to protect that community. It's
the hypocrisy of doing the thing that hurts that community most,
being the person who announces this, who brings it about, and
says, "This is what you can do, and here's how I'm going to use
it, and it's to protect this community." But you are actually
that community by engaging in any of that behavior.
And if you're just going to argue that, well, somebody was going
to kill the community eventually, I sure, but maybe.
But if somebody like were to nuke Chicago, I would blame that.
And then you just argued that well actually there was an alien
there that needed to be nuked so somebody's going to nuke Chicago.
I don't know. We might still hold that person responsible. Could
we have waited five minutes? Could we let some people get outside
the blast radius? I don't know.
>> There's just like >> Who do you think was >> I'm
trying to come up with analogy, but you know what I'm saying,
right? >> Yeah. You were saying um who do you think was
the biggest risk of this of this nuke going off? I I got my own
opinions on this and Pisco was different from mine. Um but what
do you think? >> Who do you think the biggest risk of it
going off? I don't think anybody was a big risk of it going off.
I don't think anybody was really going to have it happen because
most people don't publicize the lawsuits.
Not significantly. >> Yeah. So, I I'll just give what I
was going to say. So, I think that it was never going to be the
big companies. Um it was never going to be Sony or whatever.
I think that the only bad thing would be like an XQC or or a
content creator could do it because they have nothing to lose
almost whereas like the the big companies could lose billions.
Wait, how did the big companies lose billions?
>> Uh, okay. So, okay, let me explain that. So, they because
the big companies tried this before and they suffered massive
PR concerns. So, the music companies tried to go after a bunch
of people years ago, the movie people did and they stopped >> they
wait they no they all still go after people who like willfully
violate their copyright.
>> They absolutely don't do lawsuits anymore. They don't
like charge people like 50k per song played or something. Isn't
that just because like basically everybody built technology in
to avoid their trackers and it probably isn't worth having like
a department spun up to pursue that anymore? Like I think the
thing that used to happen was it all it was all peer-to-peer
networks and I think technologically that just doesn't happen
anymore because it's all like technologically scoped out. >> So
they just can't sue people. I I feel like you could >> Well,
they can sue people, but the way they used to do it was they
would get people's IP, they would sue the ISPs, and then they
would sue the person after they got their identity. Right. That's
how they used to do it. But now, like, you'd have to have proof
that they're doing it. They used to do it through like peer-to-peer
connections. Now, I don't know how they get proof. But if they
had proof, you're violating their their IP. I think they would
still do it. Absolutely. But also, yeah, the DMCA process exists.
That's another thing here is there's literally a a process by
which you can make sure people don't do this. And Ethan explicitly
avoided using that to increase the harm done to these
>> Sure. But that's that's not the nuke, though, right?
Like that's the point, right? Like like the point here is that
like any midsized
to large creator >> if you just want to say that this law
was a problem then yeah sure the law itself is a problem. >> Yeah.
That's all of copyright though, right? Like so so what do we
do now? I I guess maybe it's not a problem. Maybe nobody is stupid
enough to sue a thousand people and cause a billion dollars in
damages. But I
>> um I mean it's definitely going to happen again almost
as soon as it possibly can because one there's like a whole holy
war going on between these two sides. It's almost certainly going
to happen. The sad thing here is you do know that he Sorry. Okay.
It's almost certainly going to happen again,
especially given all the support that Ethan was given for doing
this. It's definitely going to happen again. But I don't know.
You probably lobby Congress to get this changed. I think what
you do is if you're doing critical commentary, you probably just
start like really excessively clipping things out and don't go
over like full VODs anymore. And if you have to miss context,
you miss context. >> Yeah. Yeah, I think I agree with you
on that. Um,
but we need >> Yeah. I I like that's where I'm at. It's
like I almost I almost feel like things are so screwed and have
been for the last 10 years and nobody is noticing this. And
I don't know if that means that I'm wrong that I think things
are just like because like I guess >> so you're saying
that the the
Well, here's the thing. I think a lot of people opt in. What
needs to happen is like the DMCA, there needs to be an evolving
like an evolution. Sorry. There needs to be an evolution of the
technological capability for like collaborating on content. So
what you need to do is if you're like going to watch somebody's
full video, you need to be able to revenue share with them somehow,
right? Like there needs to be some licensing thing going on where
you can give a license for how the content can be used. There
needs to be some like permissive license thing. And it's totally
possible, but it would be like YouTube alone can do it, right?
>> Maybe maybe you get like Rumble, maybe you get Twitch
in there kind of. >> Yes. So this actually already exists
in the music industry. There is law obligated revenue sharing
where you like are required to give your your copyright ownership
if you pay like a fee. But that doesn't this is doesn't apply
to videos yet. Like yeah, you're exactly right. Like but it has
to be like if you make a copyrighted thing, you're obligated
to
uh give it to other people based on a certain fee. >> I
mean you don't even have to make it obligated for a certain fee.
It's like basically you it's just a license system. It's already
how code works.
You just have like licensing. You just license your code. Like
when you have a a repo on GitHub, right? Right. You just have
a certain license for your code and dictates how it can be used
commercially.
You just have YouTube apply the same principle. >> You
just make it like >> you could write your own terms for
the license agreement. Yeah. Yeah. You could have your own terms
for the license agreement. You could say I want anytime my video
plays in somebody else's video, I want 100% of the revenue. And
then when somebody goes to watch that video on stream, they could
say, "Oh, well, this guy's going to take 100% of my revenue for
this duration. It I want to watch it."
Right.
>> Yeah, I agree. Like, why aren't people doing this? that
it's it feels like super obvious,
but
like YouTube like even like it like Yeah, let's say YouTube did
it like like they have some like opt-in program or something.
Uh it's just I think there's no law behind it and I think YouTube
usually waits for the law to change
um or for big legal precedents to be set big legal cases. They
wait until they're forced to change.
Just DMCA. Um, yeah. I mean, the DMCA system is imperfect. And
unfortunately, now there's a whole nuclear card you can use that
isn't the DMCA.
Oh, I also forgot. Basically, anytime you would DMCA somebody
on YouTube, you could actually just opt to sue them this way
now. You get And actually, what's funny, oh, I didn't even think
of this. YouTube basically gives you a list of targets you can
sue now, right? If you post content, YouTube actually gives you
a list of other people who have published that content, who have
used it. They'll actually give you the list of those people.
That's like the list of free money. If you register with the
Library of Congress, you can go sue all those people. That's
kind of cool. >> YouTube gives you a literal hit list.
H
>> I didn't heard anybody talk about that?
>> Oh, it is an option for DMCA rights holders on YouTube
now. Oh, but only like the ones who have it set up so that you
get like DMCA in the middle of a stream or what? I actually don't
know how it works on YouTube because
Damn. Sorry, you were about to make a point. My bad.
That's why I feel like I'm I feel like I'm like freaking crazy
because like all the stuff you're talking about is um
nobody's talking about this and it feels like a bomb should have
got gone off years ago but it hasn't and and so like why or may
or maybe we're the ones
>> because because the well at least in this space the
reason it's never gone in this got off in this space is because
uh basically if you did that in this space you would be pillaried
off of the internet before
but now we've created like a an exception for like well this
fat rancid really deserved it so actually nobody cares >> well
like did it have to be him like what if somebody if there was
somebody who didn't have anything to lose
like here's here's just an example like let's say it was me right
like like so technically not that I would ever do this but like
technically speaking like I was in that debate
right with Pisco Like, do I have copyright laws? Could I have
sued you? I I actually I I don't know. I think it's 50/50.
>> Uh, I don't think so. You needed to be So, I think to
get a copyright over something, I think you have to be crystallizing
it in some medium. And I don't think you're recording it
>> You're recording it yourself and I use your recording,
then I think so. I think that's how copyright works.
>> So, no.
Um, I would have to basically it's depends on whose copy I'm
using, right? I'm just using Pisco's copy. like you're you're
just participating on Pisco's stream. There's a reasonable understanding
that if you join his Colin's channel, you're gonna be on his
stream. If you wanted to go and say you were like dual streaming
or you're both streaming and you were recording it yourself,
you put it on YouTube and I use your stuff, then it would be.
But you don't have a copy. You don't have a right like a right
to that. >> Yeah, I guess that is very much implied license.
Well, okay, imagine somebody like me or or like Okay, because
Ethan is a very big content creator. Like imagine like a medium-sized
content creator. I I I feel like somebody would have to to do
this. It all I'm saying is all it takes is like one person. >> One
person has a >> Sure. Sure. Sure. >> But like that
I don't Yeah, I super don't care about like that part to be honest.
I just care about the guy doing it now who we should all mock
and say is like a total [__] loser. Like basically
it's it's like it's it's like we didn't realize it but we lived
in like a nuclear deterrence world, right? and Ethan Klein decided
he was losing the war and so he just actually launched a nuke
and he's just like [__] it I it know people will
nuke me back and now we're kind of in this like waiting period
where we're like what happens
we'll see
but I can still hate that guy who launched the nuke he's a loser
yeah everybody has the ability to launch a nuke it could have
happened at any time but the guy who nuked first that guy >> yeah
I I mean I'll give it to you if like like there's a nu war soon
but Um,
I don't know. I'm more of a solutionsorient oriented person.
Like, how do we how do we fix that? Do do you know any senators?
Any any congressman? >> Yeah. No, the the licensing the
permissive license thing is just easily how you fix it. It's
automatically how you fix it. But yeah, it's just the permissive
license thing 100%. You can just like opt into it. Totally works.
But then unfortunately for the permissive license thing, the
only thing that makes it weird is you need the the platforms
connected somehow. Like I don't know if that gets built open
source or if that gets built like with a government in mind or
how that gets built like something that is able to go between
these platforms and link content between them because obviously
if you just watch the VOD on Hassan stream then that's not linked
to a YouTube video that's generating revenue but it could possibly
be argued it's the same piece of content with the same copyright.
I there's something weird about multiccasting across multiple
different platforms. I'm not sure how that works. >> Yeah.
I mean I honestly I think like one or two major platforms you
get YouTube and and one other people on board and it's good,
right? But but you actually need to get YouTube on board >> realistically.
Well, I guess cuz then I guess that leaves Twitch streamer. This
is how Twitch streamers got around in the first place was YouTube
enabled DC DMCA,
right? And then like Twitch streamers just didn't care about
it because they didn't post their fods and [__] on
YouTube anyway. That's how they got away with it for a long time.
>> Yeah. Nobody noticed Twitch for for like years. Um >> I
mean people noticed like definitely the big companies noticed
but the big companies are like fortunately for everyone have
more of a soul than Ethan Klein and they just DMCA the stuff.
>> Yeah, you're not wrong actually. So like I cuz I was
at Twitch during the big uh music DMCA thing and people were
talking about how Twitch was going to explode due to this but
it just never happened. I don't know. Well, because they implemented
VOD muting for anytime DMCA music was detected. >> Yeah,
but people but that's people played it live though. >> Yeah,
but okay. People played it live. H
Yeah, I don't know. I guess I guess like the music companies
just figured as long as it's not like getting archived. I don't
know why they did that. >> No. So, so I think the actual
reason was they were they were angling for like a payment and
just like the payment kind of and so they tried this for like
years to try to get a payment. >> Did they did they just
get paid? Someone says they have licenses for music. >> I
think they did. I think they did eventually, but it took years
for them to get paid. >> Okay. All right. Interesting.
>> But but that's like on the platform level. And so that
doesn't help content creators, right? That doesn't help like
YouTube people. >> Yeah. Again, on the solution side, I
think like I tracked and followed and like actually
was making arguments for like when the original Ethan Klein saga
came up. >> I think I just said like I don't know XQC's
arguing. I I didn't mind XQC's arguments at the time mostly in
that I thought it has to be fixed legally, but
I don't know. I think he's like a like you're a bad person for
doing it. I don't know. Yeah, it's maybe again, but it ultimately
comes down to the permissive licensing thing because the way
it exists right now is like a it's like a punish me after the
fact and you get to earn all of the money. Like if you were in
a like just an intellectual property realm of somewhere else,
like if you had a part that was going in a Ford Motor and they
infringed on your IP and it made them like way more successful
and they built up all these factories and and off the back of
your patent and then you sued them and then you got like a little
bit of money,
it's like well they built up all this infrastructure. They built
up their whole company like they built something that will generate
way more revenue going forward. That's what happened with XQC,
right? is he argued like, "Oh, well, you could just sue me after."
And it's like, "Dude, you're building something that's going
to make you a ton more money than you'll just make from that
one video or owe back to that one creator." I think it's it doesn't
work without the licensing system. Like, people get paid little
bits and pieces as you grow.
Yeah. Because we have a standard for this. It was it was music
industry and radio songs, right? Because like any radio station
can play any song as long as they pay they pay this fee or
Okay. Yeah. I mean, I'm sure that could be the way it works.
You'd need maybe you see it that happen third party or something
someday.
Like clearly this could happen now, but the the coordination
would be way too expensive, right? The coordination would be
like crazy. It would be like if you had a big video for a big
creator, they'd have to set up their own person to like go through
the emails or they'd have to set up like their own platform.
I'm s I'd be surprised if somebody doesn't start
>> Like has this not existed? Does this not exist already?
>> Like a platform?
Yeah. Yeah. Nobody's doing this for actual videos. Like I actually
think we need a law. May maybe we should like
>> Okay. How many people >> You don't have to get
a law. You could just go like um >> you could just go set
up like
like a market. You could just go to some marketplace that exists
like what is it like coffee? Uh buy me a coffee or something.
Yeah. Code K-ashi, right? That that place. You can just go there
and you can set up like licenses for your YouTube videos. If
you're a YouTube creator, you can just set this up through your
Patreon even just like here's how you buy a license and if you
own a license and you're a creator like we don't DMCA you don't
sue you. >> Like it could just easily be that
be that easy. Unironically, blockchain may fix this. It's like
the one use case. No, blockchain is not required for this at
all. >> It's a website. You don't need >> C there.
The decentralization doesn't benefit this at all. Like there's
no benefit of decentralization here.
Benefit of decentralization is like from to protect from authoritarian
overreach and stuff. It's like not to or like hacking. It's like
it's not anything that would be required here.
I think smart contracts are cool for stuff like this, but it's
just that smart contracts are cool. Like the idea of a smart
contract here would be cool,
but you could just do it in a centralized way, too. Yeah, the
the the smart contract stuff is cool and having the payments
come out automatically is
but the concept of a smart contract is not really that crazy
other than the fact that it happens with an atomic transaction.
Like that's that's the cool thing about smart contracts. But
realistically, the way that works on a website is you go to a
payment processor, you pay, the payment processor sends a thing
to the actual like website logic that says you paid and then
it goes through the same way. But is it cool? Yeah, it's cool.
The idea is cool. that you could have like money that's programmable.
Yeah, it's it's pretty cool
that it's built in as a feature of the money. But right now,
we don't need programmable money. Soon though. Soon. >> Yeah.
I don't know. I'm just saying like what if like a hundred people
called senators
and they said, "Hey, we should
>> it won't matter. Can we just talk about how you think
it's like okay to compel apologies from people?"
>> Yeah. because I don't think I don't >> I don't
think it's that big of a deal and I don't have resp
because because I hate people who double, triple, quadruple down
on like dumb because that that is the worst thing you could ever
do. Like you have to
you have to stop eventually
and and that I feel like things like this stop
>> Okay,
so here's the thing. Under your I'm gonna put it in a way you
could understand. Under your way of talking about this,
what do you have what do you know about the Pixie case?
>> Um
I mean I mean more than like most people I would say. I I haven't
read any every case, but yeah. >> Sure, sure, sure. I would
just say let's say we operate in a world where
um you believe Pixie is pursuing that maliciously. Okay. I you
don't have to, but somebody somebody argues she's pursuing it
maliciously. Would you accept the argument from somebody else
that it's okay because Destiny's an elsewhere and it's so it's
okay
to have him be like financially ruined by this because he was
an on Twitch for so long. >> I I mean it wouldn't be fin.
So that's like the >> it's like totally but you have to
say that's totally fine, right? >> I would say it's the
exact same concept,
>> Sure. I think it's it's the combination of the threat
and the pull back. You always have to get somebody to pull >> But
hold on, hold on, hold on. Destiny could have just like settled
this, right? He could have just like apologized and settled this
and been like, "Oh, I'm really like, I'm so sorry. I shouldn't
have done this. It was really [__] up." >> Sure.
So if that was the goal, like based on some horrible thing he
said or or did and like you're extracting an apology from him
a and then you you don't ruin his his life, you just >> Oh,
just to be clear, >> also, she was harmed like significantly
more, I believe. Like I think the harm to her life was probably
significant more significantly more than the harm to Ethan Klein
by Casey Tron's reaction. Like in terms of the actual like criminalized
or or illegal thing that was done that they could be held liable
for the damage to Pixie is probably far higher, too. So >> yeah.
So I I guess like like there was >> Oh, also like two So
I think she asked for about $200,000 about enough to go to law
school. That's not financial ruination for him, is it? >> It's
like a penalty to make sure he doesn't do it again. But I think
I'd agree with you, right? I said if he wanted to sue for actual
damages plus lawyers fees as in whatever his lawyers cost that
would cost that Caseyron. I think that's about the same financial
penalty to both both Caseyron and Destiny in those cases. >> What
about the the cost to Casey Trron is zero. >> Well, now
it is. Sorry, but I I'm saying that I would have no problem with
Ethan charging her like a penalty. Oh, also it's not zero cuz
technically I think she's going to be on the hook for her own
lawyer's fees, right?
>> No, she got that. She got off of that. So, it was minus
lawyer lawyer base.
Oh, she gets her. Oh, okay. Oh, well, >> it's literally
zero. [laughter] Yeah, I guess there's >> I would have
been fine with her getting penalized for violating the copyright
to be honest with you. >> Yeah, I Yeah. So, my argument
would be if there is actually some hugely negative thing that
somebody is doing, um I don't necessarily mind somebody going
out of bounds on some unrelated thing to force them to make some
concession. As long as that some concession is not like some
some massive thing what like yeah an apology walk back I like
it just doesn't bother me that much like obviously actually ruing
>> as long as it is actually justified for that that main
point.
>> So like like maybe like the only the only disagreements
I might have is >> is is if if that thing is actually justified
with the Destiny case. >> Wait, hold on. So if if Casey
had refused to apologize, what would you have been okay with?
>> she refused to apologize. She refused to do anything.
She just say, "No, you can like walk away." I >> I mean
at that point like she's like deciding to ruin her own life,
right? So
>> Okay. So that's that's gets us back onto the analog
here where I believe again um I think it was suggested that lawyers
fees or sorry um like law school for Pixie would have been what
they needed before this all went to litigation. So again, I think
I think it's roughly equal. Like it wouldn't have been life ruining
for him. I I think it's about the same. So you just have no problem
with like what Pixie is doing at all. You think that's totally
fine because Destiny's been addicted to people outside of bounds?
>> The 200k is a lot. So I would say if it was at $0 and
an apology and it stopped the court cases like he had to put
out some apology. >> Zero. No, no, no, no. Like like 200,000.
What is that? >> That's a lot. That's a lot. Okay.
I would say it has to be zero. Wait for him. Hold on. You understand?
He's taken on like litigation costs that are roughly like they've
got to be four or five times that now. No. >> Sure. But
that's because he's
doing that >> because refuse to Okay. >> Yeah. But
like what I'm saying like if that's all you're asking is like
somebody to just back down like you don't even have to gain I'm
saying like you don't even gain anything. You do you gain nobody
no money. the other person doesn't lose any money and you're
just just just a backdown.
That that's that's much different than >> Hold on. She
didn't What? What did she back down on? >> I I don't know
what you said. I was I was saying like you would have >> What
did she back down? Just to back down. What did she back down
on?
>> Oh, what did Casey back down on?
She she just all she did is she got she had she gave up her
um the GoFundMe funds which she she have not she would not have
gotten if she was not sued and she just didn't gave an apology
and now she's at zero like now she is neutral if not now beneficial
right so >> what did she didn't give an apology for it
wasn't just the apology for copyright it's all the other stuff
too right >> it's extracting some penalty but Casey doesn't
have a lot of money so she can't a monetary penalty,
>> but like she's almost ahead now, right? Like like you
get that, right? She she like Okay, she she has a bit of room.
>> She she's like totally I I don't understand. Listen,
you got a very flexible spine. Okay, most people aren't like
that. Most people are like, "Oh, this is like the worst thing
you could do. Force me to apologize for something I feel I was
correct on. That's like one of the worst things you could do."
Obviously Casey wasn't getting like a lot of money. >> Like
that's the point, though. or like so like if she wasn't getting
any money before, right? That that supports my point cuz she
was broke before. Now she has more publicity, more eyes. She's
a rage baiter. She is I would say that she is the number one.
>> Do you think Do you think Casey Tron's career is going
up from here? Is that what you're about to tell me? >> I
think that Casey Tron is one of the number one rage baiters in
the entire world. And so like her having a negative reputation
is almost beneficial for her. Like literally like she's in the
top five of in the entire world for rage waiters for female raers.
>> Okay. Was she You got nothing on you,
>> I don't even
was she actually So she had no money. Was she only Is she only
now after she apologized one of one of the top rage baiters or
did she now suddenly learn how to monetize the skill of being
a rage baiter? >> No, she's been a rage baiter for 10 years.
She was like >> she was broke.
Well, she lost it and then now she's gotten sued and now she's
benefiting from it.
>> Well, okay. Because
she was she was doing nothing before. She was on the downward
trend of like becoming irrelevant
and then almost like now she is relevant. Now she could get a
bunch of donations now. Like imagine she just has a fundraiser
now of like I got sued and now I need to help my parents. She
could raise a bunch of money now. Yeah. You think so? You think
that's like a sustainable model? You think this has been good
for her career overall? >> I mean, more than she was like
>> confirm that one more time. >> She was not She
was nothing two years >> let's see here. She kind of been
nothing for a while since she got sued. Her viewership has been
up. I don't know how it's going to go after. She settles. I I
would argue that it's kind of been like totally and she's basically
like screwed over now. I I don't know where this is coming from.
you have like a lot of hope for this for as far as I could tell
like no reason. You understand she was getting like a lot of
views from Hassan's audience too, right? Like she had a lot of
Hassan's fans in her audience and she was forced to like kind
of out some stuff about Hassan.
Yeah, I guess yeah. The only argument against this is like maybe
she has signed an NDA
um and now she can't be as bombastic as she was before. >> Well,
I mean obviously she can't go after Ethan anymore, >> but
like surely there's more people than just Ethan Klein. Like like
she just >> I think you don't start ninja. >> I think
you don't understand how this >> So what that was that
her only career path is like tweeting about Ethan Quin
>> brother? I don't know that she had much of a career
path on Twitch to begin with at this point. But yeah, that was
like the the that was like the niche she was in. That's the community
she was in. You think she could rebuild like a totally different
niche doing something like completely different? you know, if
she was a little bit smart. Yeah, I I I think she could she she
could do so much. Like she she used to be famous,
>> dude, you know that guy you know that guy who goes to
um goes to like Congress in the United States? He's from like
North Korea and his like legs don't >> Dude, Kim Jong-un
did so much for that guy. Basically made that guy's career. >> It's
so amazing. >> I don't know how that happened to him, by
the I forget if they like shot his legs or if he he's like maln
I don't even remember. But it's like dude that guy he would never
be where he is now if Kim Jong-un had made sure that that guy
got [__] up. I don't even know how it happened. But
it's like that's the argument you're making right now. You know
that, right? >> I I mean
the dead beat dad. You're the You're the Debbie dad who didn't
show up to any of the baseball games. You're like, "Yeah, but
if I showed the up at the baseball games, would you be a Sai
Young winner now? It made you really want it, kid." You're like,
you're totally justifying like harmful actions and being like,
she could bounce back from this. It doesn't matter that she got
beat up. She can bounce back for sure.
>> It's not. So, you would be right if it was actually
harmful. But like I am not convinced that the the attacks on
her were actually that big of a deal. Like like you're saying
like the doomsday her life is ruined is that she can't criticize
Ethan Klein. Like like surely there's there's more to life than
only that situation. [laughter] Like she >> it's not just
about Ethan, but it's like she looks totally she I think doesn't
she look like kind of totally disingenuous to that community
now >> that she settled to Ethan? I mean she shouldn't
to be fair. She definitely shouldn't. I think Hassan came out
and said no no no like don't care about that. Of course she can
say whatever she wants about me to get out of this. >> I
just I don't think there's like much left for her. I also think
it's just >> in general in a personal way I think it's
just [__] up to compel an apology from somebody.
Um except for like the conduct you've been found liable for.
If I find you, if I I like sue you for defamation, I would expect
like a retraction that says you're you're like apologetic for
defaming me, right? I think that would be fair. But unfortunately,
he went far beyond just the uh the copyright apology. >> Yeah,
but like
look, if look, imagine you're her like there's so much you could
like just pick a random content creator who's controversial except
for I guess Ethan Klein and Asmin Gold and just attack [laughter]
them. Like [gasps] I like she used to be so she's I honestly
respect >> you understand that for a lot of people hold
on for a lot of people who do that kind of like critical content
like you I don't think it works to just like shift in and out
who you're attacking or something like it has to have some basis
for it
and also yeah we're kind of leaving alone the fact that Ethan
Klein participates in this exact same way Ethan Klein literally
just got sued and forced into an apology for another case where
he defamed somebody. Ethan Klein is literally Caseyron, but like
got an Osmpic prescription earlier. Okay. He's just ahead of
the Ampic curve on Casey Trron and he sued her. Like why should
this be the way any of that space works? >> I mean, so
so I don't know much about >> He got to enforce further.
By the way, he got to enforce further penalties on her because
of the financial differences, right? Like if Casey Tron had the
money to just take this to court and pay out some statutory penalties,
he doesn't get to enforce anything out of her. So basically,
it's just like it's just a way for rich people to go to to like
small like uh financially the you know I not as well people right
smaller streamers, smaller content creators and force them into
absurd apologies. But Ethan Klein would never be forced to do
that because he's got all the money in the world to fight all
these cases.
>> Okay. But you're just saying that apologize for defaming.
But >> you're saying that the two choices are make an apology
versus paying a bunch of money. like like so like I'll agree
that that is the choice but that that doesn't that doesn't make
the paying a bunch of money situation better.
Um you cuz you're glorifying the spend a bunch of money outcome
like like
>> it would be your choice. That's the thing. You would
have a choice. >> Sure. But this is still I still feel
like it's better for like [laughter] I don't know. I'm not convinced
that that that's like the apology is still better. Like like
you're playing this situation up of like this apology as if her
life is ruined because of this. I I just don't agree with it.
>> Okay. I think you like to be honest. I just I can't
basically you're just arguing that like you don't have any value
to
um not being forced into say things you don't believe. Like you
there's no value in that to you. >> Well, I'm I'm a very
creative person. Okay. I have I have hope for Casey Ron. Okay,
like [laughter] she she Okay, I I'm not being sarcastic when
I say that I have a lot of respect for Casey Ron because she
I mean this was 10 years ago was very funny, very smart, and
was like actually the number one rage baiter in the world for
years. And uh I mean I'm a little bit disappointed how how she
is now, but I feel like she could get back to that. She's been
about the same size content creator for like years. I don't know.
I don't know. She didn't even like really fall off from this.
>> Well, you're you're a you're a new frog then. Okay.
[laughter] You you don't understand how cool. >> Wait,
how many years ago is years ago? Wait, how many years ago is
years ago?
>> are you talking about like 10 years ago she was good?
>> That's Man, then it had nothing to do with this. >> Yeah.
I mean, I guess she wasn't that bad like 5 years ago, but like
yeah, she was I'm just saying like she was very I think she she
could do well if she tried, but maybe I guess so I guess you're
right if her spirit has been taken away from her. If she is just
giving it up now because of that, uh I guess you're right, but
I don't know. >> that feels sad. >> Um venomous villain,
this is like not analogous cuz technically he's legally allowed
to do the thing he's threatening here. So it's it's a little
different. You have to it's hard to find something that's analogous,
right?
To do things like go to an authoritarian regime where it would
would be legal to break this guy's legs. Sorry, I'm just correcting
somebody in chat. >> I I'm going to change the conversation
a little bit. Uh the question that I have for you, which is uh
why are you still a a streamer? Are are you happy with this?
I feel like Okay, you were a developer before, right? Like could
you just use curs and be a developer now?
>> Yeah. It was that was a bad question. Um I was just
curious about that. Like do you like this? >> The answer
is I just make more money doing this. >> Oh, okay. Never
mind. [laughter] >> Quite a bit more. >> Okay, forget
forget what I was saying. I just I saw a bunch of rumors on the
internet of like how you would JSTLK has has fallen off, but
but maybe I'm wrong.
>> Well, I mean, viewership is down from what it was before,
but from what I can tell, viewership's down for basically everybody.
Um, and it doesn't look great for almost anybody right now. Um,
but I still make more money doing this, so I'm quite happy doing
this. >> Okay, cool. Yeah, forget what I said
Okay. All right. >> All right. That's all I have. >> What do
you do right now for work? I actually don't know. Are you a developer
>> Yeah, I am a developer. Uh, I'm working at a
a top AI company. Not I mean, it's not like Open AI, but it's
it's like up >> Software or hardware?
software. [laughter] We rent GPUs basically. Um, which is a great
business to be in. Um,
>> like as in you run data centers
>> ba basically.
>> Uh, what is this company called?
Um, hold on. What the [__] is this company called?
How do I find this for my computer?
Don't think I can. I was going to ask if it was um it's not the
company that like got bought by Nvidia, is it? Uh that integrates
and sells like like
>> No, we we have not been bought by Nvidia. That would
be cool. But it's probably similar to that. >> Oh man,
dude. I also to be fair, I like hated working at software companies.
So um at least software companies that aren't places you go in
real in real life. So I could go do that.
>> Okay. But were you a developer before cursor AI came
out?
>> All I'm saying is like being
literally that one technology just cursor AI has changed the
entire industry. A and I don't understand people don't understand
how big of a deal that is.
It's it's like one >> I got to I did like some projects
with I don't I don't know if it's like cursor um what was it
called like it was a like code lens or something
whatever no whatever Jet Brains had integrated into their IDEs
that would do like line by line suggestions and basically like
once you had it tuned well enough you were basically just hitting
enter on a whole bunch of lines like as it wrote out what you
needed it to write out. >> Yeah it's >> what does
your workflow look like when you do that? Okay, I take the Jira
ticket that I have. I copy paste that into the prompt and I tell
it to write the code and it does. But um I so it's more complicated
than that cuz like often times like 50% of the time it's wrong
and so I read the code and then you tell it to fix the code.
So there will be a problem, a bug, uh it won't compile and you
just say like fix the the code, make it compile, and then it
just fixes that and uh that's all you do. And then now you have
a jur ticket done in like a day, which might have taken a week
before. >> That's crazy. >> Yeah. I don't I don't
write any code at all [laughter] now. >> I can see why
every job's getting outsourced to India.
Well, you you'd think that, but it's actually the jobs are going
to SF
I'm calling them 100x engineers now. Before it used to be the
10x engineer. Now it's the 100x engineer.
>> Yeah. Oh, cool. Are you you're a 10x engineer, Mr. Still
2000? >> No, no, I'm not. I'm the 100x engineer
>> Oh, okay. >> By just using AI. >> Very cool.
Um,
what was the last feature you worked on? >> Commerce web
hooks.
uh sending people emails based on if their payment failed. >> So
like like you spent money and you need to fix it. >> That
took a day. >> What was the what was the coolest feature
you worked on in the past year in 2025?
>> Honestly, there's no cool features. I work I work on
uh I I work on like data and commerce. It's not cool, but it
it's >> Okay. All right. Cool. >> That's all I had
though. Yeah. Good chatting. U Yeah. Maybe I'll leave for now.
Yeah.
>> All right. Have a good one, man. We'll talk to you later.
>> Yep. See you. >> Bye. We uh we 10x engineers fixing
bugs, doing tiny features. Damn. Damn. Damn. Damn. The game has
changed. Damn. I'm sure there's some software developers in the
crowd. They could I I asked some questions there at the end that
I think were very telling.
But that was fun. I enjoyed that. I enjoyed that a lot.
All right. Where even were we?
Oh, we were talking about Ethan. How are we on Ethan? Did I see
a tweet? Oh, it's the Pisco thing. Got it.
Got it. Sorry, Stale. I'm I'm telling you, man. Listen, I I know
some TX engineers. That's all. It's It's fine. I don't understand
anything of that last part. Okay. Oh, I'm not making fun of you
for using AI to write your code. you. I feel like that you don't
know that is
telling as well. That's all. That's all. That's all. Thank you
for coming on, Stale. I think that Hold on. How much longer do
we have on the stream? Oh, is that it? I think that's it for
today, guys. I think that's it. I think we're done with the stream.
Six more hours. What were we about to do? Were we thinking about
doing Tucker Milo? [__] me. Really?
Did I waste my time learning to code?
No, I think you can. There's jobs there. I think I really up
stopping that career path. I think what I suspect is the thing
that actually took me like a decent amount of time to do,
the thing that like was my bottleneck as a coder a lot of the
time
just like actually sitting down and writing out the stuff I knew
I had to write. Um, which sounds weird, but like the second I
had um
this is why I started doing other stuff, but the second I could
just like tell somebody what to write, like I literally know
exactly what to write, I just have a hard time like focusing.
And I got a lot better at it when I was working obviously, but
I can I tend to be like
But if I'm like focused, I'm code just flows and it's great.
And I have a feeling like with AI just being able to direct it
to do stuff, dude. I think I I think I could come up with a process.
It' be very very fast. I I'd be pushing a lot of code. I think
I'd be pushing a lot of things to prod is what I should say.
We'd be doing a lot of deploys, boys. We'd be doing a lot of
deploys.
I think I I think I would be I think I would crush it right now.
Yeah, that's the thing, Madison, is like that was always my issues.
I knew exactly what what to write, but I just had to be like,
"Okay, I'm going to go through like actually writing this right
now."
Sometime sometimes you'd get into like a feature you're building
and you would it would just be like constantly be pushing stuff
out. But if anything, I just would get like I just didn't want
to start sometimes. I don't know how to explain it.
But I I know cuz my the company I worked at, we used to we messed
around with like different um extreme programming techniques
for a long time. We do like pairing and stuff once in a while.
And holy
like I just know from from pairing that I I just know what's
going on in any system that I worked on for more than like a
week. Yeah, I know you'd have to proofread, but my company has
integrated co-pilot into integral Jupyter hub. Everyone uses
it. Internal Jupyter Hub.
You're a data analyst then. Your Jupyter notebooks were kind
of cool. I never bothered like doing anything with Jupiter, but
seemed kind of cool. Anyway, bioinformatics. Nice.
Love biioinformatics doing lots of DNA stuff. Would Would that
stuff still be like a field? I guess I can see how you'd integrate
like AI into that. But I sorry for me it's like I feel like wouldn't
that be something in terms of that in terms of that analysis?
I guess you're the person using the tools to analyze
Somehow in my head I'm like that seems like something that could
easily be solved with machine learning or or like rudimentary
AI. But I guess there lots of different questions. Okay. All
right. What is this? What is this?